Please stop oh and when are we getting
the X-Men I cannot tell you that okay okay
I'm here to help hey
you missed it, we're done sorry everything oh man
Welcomeback everyone, it's Charlie. This will be my full
She-Hulk episode 9 finale video there are a whole
bunch of Marvel Easter eggs and references they
have the biggest fourth wall break that you'll
probably ever see in Marvel anything literally at
the end of the episode they said oh no you won't
be able to access this feature again in season two
which is kind of like their in Universe version
of Kevin feige the Kevin feige robot saying you
won't be able to do this again in season two break
the show in this fourth wall kind of way she even
literally said that she smashed the fourth wall
if you're brand new to the channel I do Marvel
videos every week we have black panther wakanda
forever coming out really soon there's a bunch of
really big stuff coming up along with Daredevil
born again which they also use the end of this
episode to set up so be sure to subscribe to get
everything careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet but we'll start
at the beginning work our way through shot
by shot talking about Easter eggs WTF moments and
there's a lot of movie stuff like crossover with
the movies that they're setting up with the whole
skaar son of Hulk stuff that I'll talk about too
like you have all the stuff that they were paying
off from She-Hulk season one and then all the
other movie stuff that they were setting up even
though they joked about that too like whose show
is this that's literally the title of the episode
them calling out and clowning on bad Marvel movies
and bad Marvel TV show endings a lot of the fourth
wall breaking in this episode is Marvel making fun
of Marvel for example her breaking the fourth
wall in that epic way at the end of the episode
to literally change the putt like she retcons her
own episode would be like Daenerys Targaryen for
example in the Game of Thrones finale breaking
the fourth wall and going to the Game of Thrones
writer's room in making them change the plot so
that she has a much better ending and because one
of Deadpool's big things is breaking the fourth
wall it'd be like Deadpool in Deadpool 3 breaking
the fourth wall and taking Hugh Jackman and
literally walking from the fox lot to the Disney
lot like that's how big their fourth wall break
was in this episode this time there's no cold open
but what they do is they start with the regular
Marvel Studios logo and then it transitions into
a version of the 1970s Incredible Hulk TV show
intro with new voiceover made to look like it
was actually happening back in the 1970s but it's
all the She-Hulk plot weaved into this some of
it Incorporated plot from the She-Hulk series and
some of them are like literal copies of the intro
from The Incredible Hulk TV series the voiceover
dialogue is basically the plot of the series they
bring it back again later in the episode where
she's like no no breaking the fourth wall we're
not going to do a voiceover in this series this
also isn't even the first time that she's broken
the fourth wall to affect the She-Hulk riders in
the Kevin robot earlier when she asked them to
redo the previously on she would have had to be
speaking to the same people making the She-Hulk
show they work in pictures of Todd with the fondue
to set up the whole bit with him being the Hulk
King behind the intelligentius stuff confirming
a lot of our theories after last week's episode
like he seems so sus after last week's episode
and even though during her fourth wall break in
the second half of the episode she retcons the
plot of the finale they don't completely retcon
all the Todd stuff like that all happened she just
retcons some aspects of it they do a bit about the
online trolls with the Intelligentsia but it's
a classic 1970s era computer with her typing on
an old looking Forum like it would have been if
she were interact acting with those characters
during the 1970s they finally pay off that classic
don't make me angry saying that they put in the
original trailers like this is directly from the
Incredible Hulk TV series and they're dressed like
the characters from that series like the Bruce
Banner character is dressed exactly like the
David Banner character was in that series during
this scene don't make me angry you wouldn't like
me when I'm angry Mr McGee don't make me angry you
wouldn't like me when I'm angry and they end this
1970s intro with the same type of titles from the
Incredible Hulk TV series in the 1970s but they
finally used the Savage She-Hulk name from the
comics I think they've referenced Savage She-Hulk
before but this is the first time they've actually
written it on screen during her very first solo
comic book it was the Savage She-Hulk like that
was her number one issue which is being read
by the Kevin robot in the end credits scene the
actual opening scene is her waking up inside the
damage control prison just like the Abomination
cell that he was in even though they do wind up
changing the plot during the second half of the
episode with her big fourth wall break this huge
retcon that she pulls all the stuff that happens
in the first part of the episode still happens
canonically within her story in the MCU so like
the Intelligentsia always came after her tried to
steal her blood I think what she changed though
with the retcon is that Todd's experiment in
replicating the powers of the Hulk with her blood
were unsuccessful like that's the only thing that
she changed about the Intelligentsia plot all the
other stuff really happened she didn't change that
so the first part of the episode is dedicated to
her tracking down what actually is going on with
these intelligentia characters and revealing Todd
to be behind all this for at least the first part
of the episode she has to wear the ankle bracelet
that Abomination and Bruce Banner wore for a lot
of the series although we find out what was really
going on with abomination 2 confirming some of our
suspicions but it was a bit of a Twist like they
kind of set him up for Thunderbolts and Captain
America four stuff but not in the way that I
thought that they were going to set him up for
that I'll explain more of that when we get to that
part of the episode they imply that at least for
a little while her Law Firm fires her because
their whole thing is that they just wanted her
for She-Hulk not for Jennifer Walters and if she
can't be a she look anymore then there's no point
in her working at the law firm when she goes back
to live with her parents all of her posters are
from the early 2000s because that's when she would
have been in college and they're all legal themed
movies like Legally Blonde Aaron Brockovich they
introduced the new dance video that she created
in school with her friends which is also kind of
a call back to her twerking like a lot of this
is meant to be meta jokes referencing earlier
moments in the series that people were upset
about like a lot of them making fun of the trolls
in Intelligentsia is them making fun of fans in
real life getting upset at the show so like all
the Intelligentsia characters are meant to be
proxies for the real-life She-Hulk TV show haters
so when she breaks the fourth ball the first time
she says wait a minute this seems wrong it's her
acknowledging that she's not in control of her own
story and the whole idea during the series like
the whole actual story as she talks to the Kevin
robot later is meant to be about her finding
the balance between being She-Hulk and being
Jennifer Walters lawyer by day so once she breaks
the fourth ball like once it gets super meta it's
her like literally and metaphorically taking
control of her own story and actually doing
that she references the show going off the rails
which is another reference about shows introducing
big twists just for the sake of twists that don't
make any sense while she's still in the middle of
her fourth wall break they have the bit with her
stopping the announcer voice like announcer we're
not doing this anymore go away when she tries to
get a hold of Bruce Banner Hulk again you notice
her handle for him is the smug hold I believe
we saw this earlier in the series where her joke
was that she was calling him the smug version of
the Hulk most of these people and all of her text
messages on on her phone here are just her friends
and co-workers some of these random people might
also be crew members from the actual show she
breaks the fourth wall again to announce that
she's going to visit Abomination Nikki uses the
college dance video to get pug in to see what's
happening with the Intelligentsia characters also
at The Retreat she meets the Thunderball member of
wrecking crew again and remember the whole thing
with them is they were trying to get her blood so
they were actually working for the Intelligentsia
for Todd Hulk King but I think the whole idea with
his character is that he's actually meant to be
genuine in the previous episode when he said that
he was done with all that stuff because during
the episode he just seems like he wants to be a
nice friend to her the book He's reading is also
the book you see her reading later Abominations
book on haikus that he referenced earlier on
the series he has started to read then to her
while he was still in his cell that a lot of the
complaints that the trolls are making inside the
Intelligentsia meeting is meant to be them
calling out a lot of real life trolls like
they're complaining about female Thor which is a
reference to Jane Foster in Thor love and thunder
Todd literally reveals he's behind everything
he's behind the website he is Hulk King and he
explains that he was trying to turn himself self
into another version of The Hulk and even though
they do it briefly in the episode here like I said
that's like the one thing that they retcon when
she breaks the fourth wall to talk to Kevin in the
final canonical version like after she's made all
these changes to the actual plot everything is
still the same except he was not successful in
turning himself into a version of the Hulk right
before Jennifer Walters rushes down to meet them
their Thunderball references saracen again
remember he's the vampire I just posted my
full Easter egg breakdown video of the werewolf
By Night Special the link will be in the comments
below but they were going to do blade during
that but there was some scheduling issues but
they're setting at larger Supernatural characters
in the MCU I talked about this during my previous
episode video too werewolves vampires man thing
other Supernatural characters like Ghost Rider
is another good example of that too we find that
Abomination has been breaking his parole by going
into full form by taking off his inhibitor chip
also putting it on the chickens which they pay off
in the end credit scene too like you see someone
putting it on one of the chickens which explains
why he was so fond of the chickens and the way
they play this he says that he was just doing it
to earn the my money like he's not connected to
Intelligentsia or any of that plot like he was
genuinely just in it for the money so when things
get crazy and he tries to help her start the rest
of the crowd from getting at her they just want to
show you that he's genuinely being a pretty decent
guy but breaking the law which is why he turns
himself in and goes back to his cell before he
accepts Wong's offer for Asylum and kamartaj I was
expecting him to be lying about something but he
just came off way nicer than I was expecting they
pay off the whole blood storyline where at least
before the retcon he actually uses the serum
on himself turns himself into a version of the
Hulk but that only lasts for like a couple seconds
before things really get crazy when Titania busts
in and she keeps breaking the fourth wall like
wait a minute this doesn't make sense things are
completely off the rails do you feel satisfied
she's talking to us the audience asking us if we
feel like the episode has gone off the rails just
as Bruce Banner Hulk deus ex machina busts in and
starts having a rematch with the Abomination like
he literally comes out of nowhere which they also
do at the end of the episode too when Daredevil
comes out of nowhere but that's because she asked
for that to happen and then she breaks the fourth
wall and probably the most extreme way that we've
ever seen at least in any of the Marvel series
even like Rick and Morty which breaks the fourth
wall in crazy ways all the time hasn't broken
the fourth wall in this big away even when we
get to Deadpool 3 I'm not expecting him to break
the fourth wall in this extreme kind of way and
the way they're playing this fourth wall break
she's talking to the audience about them being
not satisfied like don't you feel like this
episode has gone completely off the rails
and they're playing it as if we the audience have
turned the episode off like we backed out like no
we're not going to watch the episode anymore and
it's like we're inside Disney Plus in Universe hey
what do you think you're doing this menu is not
going to stop me but because of the way her powers
work with this fourth wall breaking she's still
talking to us from inside the system so to speak
inside Disney plus and then literally breaks
out of her show and swings down into the Marvel
assembled show the behind the scenes show for
all the movies in the series she also hurts the
Loki series a little bit to do this so sorry Loki
when she breaks out of the episode into real life
the aspect ratio changes from the typical Marvel
movie aspect ratio to the 16x9 aspect ratio so
that's how you can tell when she's in real life
and when she's actually in the episode she walks
onto the Disney lot where they're actually in the
middle of making the She-Hulk show and this is the
real Disney lot in Los Angeles and this is the
actual writer staff on the She-Hulk series like
Jessica Gallo the showrunner is this person in
the red shirt when she breaks into the writer's
room there's another QR code you can scan to get
another free Shield comic book and they have one
of many Captain America posters but it's then
the style of the old-timey World War II Uncle
Sam posters those are all over this part of the
episode in different parts of the Marvel Studios
lot I think that's just meant to be another joke
about the Marvel secrecy like everywhere Marvel
is watching you making sure you don't give away
their secrets they have the same Captain America
poster inside the room if you look around the room
the way it's decorated it seems like the actual
She-Hulk writers room like I literally think that
they took the camera and filmed inside the actual
real life writer's room over on the right this is
all concept art of characters that we saw earlier
this season it's real Marvel Studios concept
art for the actual series like they didn't fake
created just for this episode they have all the
episode beats plotted out on cards across all the
walls that's pretty standard for a Rider's room
the writing on the board has phrases referencing
stuff from early this series like cousin ched's
in cheddable Hulk joke there are also a couple of
jokes too like most of this is meant to be real
but there are a couple extra jokes they added
for this like the whole joke here is She-Hulk
taking them to Tas saying that you came up with
a crappy episode because the writers thought that
they needed a Twist because they're supposed to
be a Twist at the end of all the Marvel series
and Marvel movies she looks big argue document
is that she was trying to say that that's bad
like everything feels like it's the same oh the
villain is trying to steal the powers of the hero
haven't we done that before that's also a joke
about the first Iron Man movie because literally
during that movie Obadiah stain steals his power
of the arc reactor to make his own Iron Monger
suit his version of the Iron Man suit like I said
throughout the second half of the episode all
these scenes are basically Marvel making fun of
Marvel and also joking about writers having twists
and finales for no other purpose than to just have
a Twist and it being really crappy on the board
you see it says there's no wowie at the end that's
also calling out a lot of finales that don't have
twists and that's meant to be the big twist like
ah what if we didn't do anything and that was the
twist when they say they're only doing what Kevin
wants obviously that's a reference to Kevin feige
but in the episode instead of having the actual
real-life Kevin feige they have a robot Kevin
and that's meant to be a joke about Kevin feige
being so prolific like he makes so many Marvel
movies so many TV shows you'd have to be a robot
to have the energy to do all that stuff Shield
makes a joke about them churning out a bunch of
land superhero movies and shows like the actual
episode clowns on Kevin feige himself a little
bit in the other joke here too about Kevin feige
is the in the episode they play it like he's meant
to be this Untouchable figure that nobody ever
gets to see but in real life actual Kevin feige
visits the sets of the Marvel movies the TV shows
that they make talks to everybody and everybody
for the most part says he's a pretty chill dude
like he's actually really cool to work for and the
other joke here with her trying to break into his
office is that Kevin feige said that he actually
does have an office but he rarely actually spends
any time in it sitting behind a desk like any time
you see him in like one of those promos sitting
in front of a desk that seems like his office he
doesn't actually do that most of his time is spent
walking around visiting writers rooms or visiting
the sets of the movies so even though technically
he does have an office like he never spends any
time in there when she actually goes to the Marvel
Studios offices these are the real Marvel Studios
offices like this is a picture of Ryan Reynolds
visiting the Marvel Studios offices obviously
looks exactly the same like I said they have
the big joke about her signing the famous Marvel
non-disclosure agreement and she has a joke about
it being super long like she gets really surprised
when she sees how long it is like she keeps
scrolling and scrolling and scrolling looking for
the signature part that's all real they actually
do make everybody sign non-disclosure agreements
that will basically sue you out of existence if
you reveal any of their secrets which I also think
they're using for a Mark Ruffalo joke just because
of Mark Ruffalo and Tom Holland being the spoiler
Bros like it's a Hulk series they're making a joke
about keeping secrets obviously Mark Ruffalo the
Hulk you have to make a little bit of fun of him
giving away all Marvel Secrets all the time then
when she has her version of a hallway scene it's
meant to be like a parody of a daredevil hallway
scene and kind of like a Black Widow Iron Man
2 hallway scene too with the way it looks these
hallways are not from the actual real Marvel
Studios like this is where it transitions to an
actual set and this is not what the door to Kevin
feige's office looks like like there's no elevator
that goes to his office all the art on the walls
is real life concept art from the previous Marvel
movies they have another one of those same Captain
America posters like watching you like I'm asking
you not to give away our our secrets and when
she actually breaks into Kevin feige's office
they play the Marvel Studios Fanfare music and
this set looks exactly like the Disney plus green
screen set where Kevin feige did his Marvel phase
4 presentation where they revealed the very first
She-Hulk trailer and because of the way they're
breaking the fourth wall in this like canonically
the way this is all meant to work is is She-Hulk
reacting to the knowledge that she is a fictional
character in a show and Kevin created her like he
created Bruce Banner all these other characters
wrote their stories and filmed them as if he is
the actual camera himself the other big joke here
being that he's the sophisticated algorithm that
thinks that he knows exactly what superhero movies
are supposed to be and just generates them out of
nothing you also notice as they're panning around
the room he has a bunch of comic books spinner
racks a lot of these comics are also of the brand
new characters they just introduced like one of
the comics here is an American Chavez comic book
they're also using this joke to say that the Kevin
robot basically absorbs the information from these
Comics to get his ideas for how to make the Marvel
movies which is a reference to Kevin feige in in
real life making the Marvel movies be more like
the comics when they zoom in on Kevin's face even
though his face looks like an actual camera on the
top it looks like he's wearing a little hat that's
meant to be a reference to all the hats that Kevin
foggy wears in real life typically you can tell
what project he's working on because he'll change
his hat just based on whatever he's actually doing
at any given moment the only bummer here is that
they didn't use real life Kevin feige's voice
for the robot Kevin feige his acronym stands for
knowledge enhanced visual interconnectivity Nexus
which I also think is meant to be a bit of a wink
at the one division Nexus jokes like a lot of the
complaints that She-Hulk is making to Kevin is
about these big plot points that they think that
they're supposed to be paying off like the blood
plot point and they kind of did that during one
division there are also some other references
to Benedict Cumberbatch's Doctor Strange in one
division during this scene too when she complains
to Kevin about having Hulk come out of nowhere to
save her inside her own show that was the reason
they said that they chose not to include Benedict
cummerbatch Dr Strange In One Division because
they didn't want like some other dude to come
into the story and save Scarlet Witch they wanted
her to save herself and that's kind of the same
argument that She-Hulk is making to the Kevin
robot also super meta connection to Rick and
Morty too another series that breaks the fourth
ball but they just had an episode where they made
a ton a ton of Marvel movie jokes and the episode
was also about them not paying off big plot points
that they had set up a long time ago so like a lot
of the things that they're doing in the She-Hulk
finale are things that they literally just did
inside the Rick and Morty episode this week I just
posted my video for that so I'll put a link in the
description below and Jessica GAO the showrunner
on Shield also came directly from the Rick and
Morty series her last big episode that she did was
the pickle Rick episode in season three Rick and
Morty also tells a lot of Marvel jokes because a
lot of the Rick and Morty writers have been stolen
by Marvel and are now working on Marvel movies for
example two Rick and Morty Riders are now writing
Avengers 5 King Dynasty in Avengers 6 Secret Wars
the Kevin robot makes a joke about real life Kevin
feige saying were you expecting a man they make
a meta joke about the special affects budget for
She-Hulk and all the Hulk characters being super
expensive to do with special effects so could you
please change back to being a human because it's
cheaper to film you as a human during episodes
when they cut away and she makes the change they
play the music cue from Black Panther they make a
joke about some of the Marvel movies and TV shows
being bad like the robot says some are better
than others but I will leave that debate for
the internet which is exactly what it's like in
real life she references the title of the episode
when she says to him that it's her show she should
get to decide what happens like the title is whose
show is this she references the actual Marvel
Cinematic Universe clowning on a lot of the
movies ending in similar ways and makes a Captain
America Super Soldier serum joke that's also
a reference to the origin of the Hulk character
like the accident that actually gave him his gamma
abilities he was working on a derivative program
based on the super soldier serum Thunderbolt Ross
had him working on the next iteration of the
weapons plus program which is the super soldier
serum program also on this series they reference
the Abomination was given a derivative of the
super soldier serum so literally he was given the
super soldier serum that's also a bit of a meta
joke about the Thunderbolts movie like there
are a lot of characters on that Thunderbolts
team that are super soldiers in this whole part
of the fourth wall break with her arguing about
what the plot should be like what they should be
changing it to is her explaining the whole show
to the actual audience to us the audience who
were probably expecting it to feel more like an
action-oriented Incredible Hulk sequel movie she
retcons a couple aspects of the finale like not
everything just a couple small parts and when
the robot says they were going to explain what
Hulk was doing in space on sakar she says save
it for the movie obviously that's set up for the
reference to skaar son of Hulk at the end of the
episode because they do pay it off like that's a
real thing it is Canon now in the movie where she
references them paying that off in a bigger way is
probably going to be Captain America 4 New World
Order because the main villain with that is going
to be the leader from The Incredible Hulk movie
so there's just like a lot of Hulk related stuff
happening between that in the Thunderbolts movie
so they might wind up paying off some of the skaar
son of Hulk plot during the Thunderbolts movie
as well like it might cross over between captain
America 4 and Thunderbolts I talked about this
earlier like them setting up a whole world war
Hulk Arc in the movies that's what this is about
they basically confirmed a lot of my theories
she brings back Daredevil because he's awesome of
course she'd bring him back and she just got with
him like she also makes a joke about that too
I smash a lot of things including Matt Murdock
sometimes she complains about all the Avengers and
the Guardians of the Galaxy having the same types
of daddy issues because a lot of them do have
daddy issues she also made a joke about that in
the first couple of episodes I believe too really
enjoyed the X-Men reference when she complains
about them not doing X-Men yet and then Winks at
us the audience like she's doing us a solid like
hey guys I'm looking out for you I'm asking for
those X-Men but the thing is since they made this
episode they probably didn't have time to change
this but since then they've announced Deadpool 3
Hugh Jackman's Wolverine is coming back he is like
a core X-Men character so they already are kind of
doing X-Men but I think when you're talking about
the X-Men spin-off movie they might wind up doing
that during Marvel phase six if they don't push
it till after Secret Wars they've been setting
up all kinds of mutants like Namor is going to be
a mutant and black panther when kind of forever
Miss Marvel was a mutant during her series that
just happened a little while ago so there'll be
a lot of mutant stuff happening across Marvel
Phase 5 and Marvel phase six I also love when
the Kevin feige robot is like I can't tell you
about the X-Men yet when she starts referencing
She-Hulk season 2 I think they do have loose
plans for a season two like nothing has ever a
done deal till it actually happens but I think
they have planned for her to potentially get a
season two but then when the Kevin feige robot
clowns on her about being in the movies like I
will see you on the big screen and she's like
wait a minute you mean for real she's talking
about being in the upcoming movies and he's like
no I don't mean that I think the joke there is
that she actually will be in the movies like she's
talking to Marvel right now signing contracts for
that kind of stuff and she'll probably come back
for a lot of the skaar son of Hulk stuff that they
pay off in Captain America 4 in the Thunderbolts
movie the whole idea is that all these brand new
characters are introducing on the Disney plus
series are meant to cross over into the movies
she makes a bunch of Hulk smash references like
she talks about smashing the plot of the episode
as well as smashing the fourth wall and then
obviously like I said smashing Matt Murdock
then when she comes back to the actual episode
like the actual plot picks up again what they're
saying canonically now based on all the changes
she made is that all the intelligensia stuff
still happened the way that you saw it but
the one minor change is that Todd was not
successful in his attempts to steal the powers of
the Hulk they all get arrested she's going to sue
him out of existence which they pay off later
in the episode and then the funny part here is
the Daredevil kind of like Hulk earlier deus ex
machina comes out of nowhere because she asks
the Kevin feige robot to do that we also find out
that Titania is a huge Daredevil fan who wouldn't
be a daredevil fan Abomination turns himself in
and like I said they're playing him as if he is
a generally good person now like he's not meant
to be evil he's just bending the rules to try
and earn some money and I think because of what
he said earlier in the post-credits scene when
he takes Asylum income martaj he essentially
becomes a fugitive so Val might take advantage
of that during the Thunderbolts movie and say if
you come help us then I'll help get you back into
the country legally like you won't have to worry
about that anymore she's another family meal with
her entire family like she did before only this
time Murdock is there they make a bunch of Matt
Murdock Daredevil jokes and I think a lot of this
is also meant to set up the events of Daredevil
born again like oh yes I have a practice in Hell's
Kitchen I grew up there this is why I help people
this is why I don't earn a lot of money because
I try to help people who do not have money he
also says that he's staying for an entire week
so it sounds like they're going to be smashing
for quite a while I also kind of think she might
wind up cameoing at some point during Daredevil
Born Again episodes but it would be her going to
New York City because I think most of the plot
will take place in and around New York City for
that then obviously big WTF moment of the episode
Bruce Banner Hulk shows up for real this time and
introduces them to his son skaar son of Hulk right
out of the comics so the whole thing is this came
after the planet hole comics and World War Hulk
basically it's them confirming that the sakhar
spaceship came to get him because he was learning
that he had a son for the first time and the idea
is that while he was on sakhar in the contest
of Champions in full Hulk form his mind had been
suppressed so much that he just was not conscious
of what happened during that two-year Gap so the
idea is that during that period hope got busy with
a woman and he's just learning about it now and
like I said they probably will not pay that off
till Captain America 4 maybe some of the movie but
it'll be like their version of an MCU World War
Hulk plot then they show her at the actual trial
where she's going to sue Todd and all the other
intelligensia members she declares on the news
that she's going to continue being a vigilante
like she says she's coming for the bad guys
in court and out of court I believe the phrase
difficult Diva of law is also from The Shield
comics and then during the end credits scene
where they have all these new scenes the new ones
that they added are the scene of the Abominations
retreat with them putting abomination's inhibitor
on the chickens just to help him get around it and
use his power so they could earn more money from
these speaking engagements they have the Kevin
robot reading a She-Hulk comic book and it's
the very first issue of savage She-Hulk they
show Todd at their trial in the background or all
the other members of Intelligentsia sweating it
out because they're about to go to jail the song
that's playing over this is a Missy Elliott remix
of Rapper's Delight from the Sugar Hill Gang and
then in the post-credit scene they pay off Wong
offering Asylum to Abomination at kamartaj he
accepts the offer they make another reference
to him watching another TV show like that's
Wong's big thing in his free time is watching
TV shows probably hanging out with Madison
the joke about the Wi-Fi is a callback to
the first Doctor Strange movie the password
for the Wi-Fi in that movie was Shambhala
oh what's this my mantra
the Wi-Fi password and like I said I think
this is all set up for him being recruited
by Val to the Thunderbolts and that'll be his
way of clearing his record so he can come back
into the country legally obviously there's like
a billion things going on in this it got super
meta way weirder than I was ever expecting if
he's spotted any other Easter eggs or references
in the episode that I didn't talk about in the
video just write down below in the comments or
if you have any big questions about plot points
or the way that they play things in these fourth
wall breaks I'm working on a new black panther
wakanda forever trailer video that should post
really soon we're also going to get the very first
Ant-Man 3 Quantumania trailer with a whole bunch
of Kang so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that everyone click here for my
Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer video and click
here for my She-Hulk episode 8 Daredevil video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!